Say what?
I am sleepy mint.
Double audio?
There we go.
I am astrobot.
Sleepy mint.
I am sleepy mint.
Yeah!
Sleepy mint.
I am sleepy mint.
Thank you for the 20 gift!
Astrobot.
I am astrobot.
Ass.
Astrobot.
I am astrobot.
He says it himself!
Welcome back, master and madam!
If you're wondering why is Mintok so sleepy...
It's because I've been fighting the jet hag.
A.K.A.
Jet lag.
I'm ham!
From Japan!
And boy are my arms tired.
Thank you!
Jet lag is strong.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to Burly.
Happy birthday to you.
Welcome back, Mintok!
And you're
probably like, why is Mintok with Chibi if she's home?
Because I kind of got used to it.
But also I feel like Chibi looks good for this game, maybe.
I think.
Welcome to your house.
Thanks!
What a no sleepy girl.
Astrobot.
Thanks for the bird!
Glad you got to see a shoebill.
I know I was happy to see a serval in a zoo a few years ago.
I want to see serval!
I want to see friend!
I am...
I...
Yeah, I went to the zoo to see only the shoebill.
Luckily...
That was my main goal because I really didn't get to see much of anything else because the zoo was closing.
And Draco thanks for the turning of bird!
Did the shoebill eat you?
Does it look like you did?
I'm Astrobot.
Astro-bot.
I am Astro-bot.
I have Chibi energy.
I have no energy right now.
I took a nap earlier.
I didn't really do much but I think I made it worse, maybe.
I think I made it worse.
Astro-bot.
This song goes hard.
I could listen to it for like a whole hour.
Astro-bot.
I am Astro Bot.
I've seen so many good things about this game.
I'm ready to be Astro Bot.
I keep wanting to say Astro Boy.
Are you giving your cats a good scratch?
Yes!
They've been so cute.
My cats, I think they missed me a whole lot.
They were so cute.
Except today I scared Paz and she farted.
And the smell burnt into my nose for like the whole rest of the day.
And that wasn't good.
Happens to the best of us.
Have you ever been so spooked you farted?
That's my question.
Girl, that's my girl.
The chemical attack.
Deployed the chemical attack.
She smelt it.
She dealt it.
She had a natural reaction.
Like a real in the wild type of reaction you would expect, right?
How did you roll the two stinkiest cats ever?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
Wait, is that you Lamba Delta?
It's cut off.
All I see is lamb.
Thank you for the Okazoba.
Congratulations on beating Unmetal Gear.
Can't watch the stream when it's live because I have so much work to do.
I'm going to watch the VOD later to see the silliness of the game.
Can't wait for the hack and slash.
Unmetal Gear Rising Revengeance where you play as Jack Lightning.
No
worries.
If you can't watch, I appreciate watching the VOD.
My cat threw up all over the house and made me work late this morning.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Infiltrate space and capture all the bots.
I actually don't know really anything about this game.
Just that there's like a bunch of like other game properties in it and I think that's fine.
So I'm excited to see.
I saw...
Not to like spoil so much.
But of course I knew that Metal Gear is in it.
I saw that Metal Gear is in this game.
And then I saw Katamari.
And that's basically all I know.
I don't really know what the...
I think it's a platformer, right?
I've never seen Escape from New York.
But I borrowed it from the library.
Let's see what Snake Pliss...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Escape from New York?
For some reason I wanted to say Attack from New York.
Escape from New York is so good.
The game is cute.
I'm excited to try it.
Let's try it.
I don't know how long I'll be able to stream today because my brain is really tired.
I am tired, Mint.
Now Mint has to prove how much of a hag she is with these retro games.
Oh boy.
Time to show my hag levels.
Oh cute.
It's even the memory card.
Oh stop.
Wait.
How retro are we getting?
It's so cute.
Oh my gosh.
The little wink here.
I like how Astro Bot just kind of became like the mascot.
Right?
I guess one memory card.
I think I still have mine somewhere.
I am Astro Bot.
Astro Bot.
This game is pretty.
Am I supposed to move anywhere?
This game is so pretty.
Oh wait.
That's a PS5.
Oh wow.
Let's party.
Like it's 1999.
Uh oh.
Oh and if you are wondering, I have not played the other Astro Bot games.
So this is my first one.
Oh my god.
He is...
He is going to take it.
He is going to take everything from...
No.
That's my favorite part.
Oh.
The PS5.
Can Astro Bot breathe in space?
How is the audio by the way?
I think he just put that up his...
His hole.
Oh.
I think he just put...
He just stole that from us and put it up his hole.
Audio is good?
Thank you guys.
He stuck it up where?
That's what I'm saying.
Oh cute.
Oh my gosh.
It's like the controller I'm holding right now.
Cute.
I feel like this game would have been good for 3D huh?
Oh!
He escaped.
Put it up.
He put it right in the...
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
Look how cute he is.
What else can we do?
We can jump.
We can fight.
Thank you, Link.
What else can we do?
Can I attack this thing?
I'm trying to pet him.
Oh my gosh!
I'm so sorry!
That was an aggressive... it was like cuteness aggression, you know?
You sound like a monkey.
Oh wow!
Currency.
Oh wait, what?
Jump?
I did it!
Oh my gosh, I saw like this...
I saw like this TikTok the other day.
That was like...
It was titled like when you're... oh my god.
Is that a PSP?
It was like when you're... when you're teaching your girlfriend how to play a game.
But it really just felt like when a streamer is playing a game.
Because it was just like... it was the guy who was just like...
Okay, I'm gonna show you... I'm gonna show you Cuphead.
And she gets through... she's like playing the tutorial.
And then she's like...
She's like, why is it... why am I going against a boss so early?
And it's just like she doesn't know how to jump and dash.
I'm not explaining it very well.
But it's silly.
Everybody loves Ice Monkey.
Well, here's Astro Monkey.
Amatai.
Oh my god, he's dead!
Astro Bot is dead!
No!
I just started!
He has so many idle animations.
Oh, what else does he do?
He's so cute!
Ah!
He's dead!
Rip Bozo.
Okay.
Anyway.
Anyway, just that... that part reminded me of the video I watched.
That's all I was trying to say.
Oh my gosh, look at the trails it leaves in the sand.
It has... it's so... it looks so...
It's so good!
Oh my gosh.
It feels like forever since I've played like a...
I don't know.
Would you call it...
I don't...
I wouldn't call it maybe...
I don't know.
A triple A title.
But like it's been so long since I've played like a...
A big game that has like a high budget and it's come out recently.
So I'm like not used to high graphics right now.
You know what I mean?
No!
Oh my gosh!
He waved!
So cute!
Yeah!
A modern game?
So for me, I'm just like wow!
Attention to detail!
So cool!
It's so high def!
Hey!
Oh my gosh!
I didn't think hitting him would actually work.
Beep boop bop!
Beep beep beep beep!
Yeah!
So cute!
I want my own...
Oh!
What am I doing?
Controller sounds, etc.
mimic on what you walk on.
Welcome back, Minto.
Thanks, Chucky!
No way!
Well, actually I can't really hear the controller sounds because of my headphones.
I don't know if you guys can.
I'm holding it close to the mic right now.
Where do we go?
Oh!
Scan...
Or boost...
Where do we go?
Chameleon?
I think we have to go to monkey.
Gorilla Nebula!
Okay!
Wait, hold on.
What's the boost do?
Wow!
Oh!
The trigger feels so good!
Sorry, I probably sound like I'm shilling this.
It just all feels so new!
I'm so excited!
I've played too many retro games recently.
Aaaaah!
No!
Pew pew pew pew!
Okay, here we go.
Dive in!
Oh my gosh, I saw flamingos at the zoo recently!
There was like this one flamingo that was...
Okay, all the flamingos were pink, you know?
Flamingos are pretty cute.
They're pink because they eat shrimp.
That's where they get their pink color from.
But there was one flamingo that was gray.
And I was like, is he sick?
Or is he... I don't know.
I was like, what's wrong with...
Or maybe he's a baby flamingo.
And...
They were like... there was like...
They were doing like a mating ritual or something.
Unless he's a baby.
But I got it all on camera.
And I was like, me and who?
Are we diving in?
Oh, I have to hold it down.
There we go!
First level, let's go!
They're so pink here.
Oh, this is how I move.
Okay.
We're coming in hot!
Oh, it's just like Outer Wilds.
What's this?
Yeah!
Okay, punch the trees!
Yeah, punch the trees!
Trees ain't got nothing on me!
Bitcoin!
I'm gonna punch these guys.
Oh, are you a friend?
I think...
I think he was a friend.
Okay, I think I gotta get up here.
And get... I don't know...
Quite the point...
The point of the coins yet, but...
Depth perception?
How many shrimps do you have to eat before he makes your skin turn pink?
Eat too much and I'll get sick.
Shrimps are pretty rich.
What is this a reference to?
Yeah...
A song?
What song?
It's an old song.
You haven't heard flamingo?
I guess not.
Oh!
This guy is trying to steal my loot!
Yeah!
Take that, idiot!
This is what you get for trying to steal from me.
Wait... wait...
I guess I could have gone this way, huh?
Whatever...
I think I got everything.
He's so cute.
He's yelling...
to nobody.
Anybody who will listen to him talk.
You said it's yours.
It's my money now!
Yeah?
Oh!
I rescued a bot!
Oh
my gosh!
Wait!
That's so cool!
I'm actually controlling it!
You can see me pushing the buttons even!
It's like nipples!
Yeah!
Okay.
What's this?
I'll take that.
Attack!
Oh!
Evil!
Yeah.
Oh my gosh!
We're restoring the planet!
I have to beat these guys up to rescue them.
It's so sad.
Oh!
Yeah!
You guys like it in there?
I've gone mad with power!
I have Shaken Bot Syndrome, maybe.
What's this?
Oh!
Yoshi!
Take that!
We can even play some football!
Yeah!
Screw you!
One jerk ruins it for everybody.
There's a secret ball!
Okay.
Let's grab this.
Wait!
This is so fun already!
Wow!
Wee!
Is this like a checkpoint, I'm guessing?
Oh!
Fun!
Come on!
Destroy!
Whoa!
Yeah!
This is so nice after...
After having played...
What's it called?
Mario 64.
It feels so good!
Okay.
Square and pole!
Is that guy yelling up there?
Wait!
Is that...
Ratchet?
Is that Ratchet?
Tooled up mechanic!
He's tooled up!
I'm boggling them.
His little buddy's got his back.
He's cute!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
You guys, when we find Snake, I might cry!
What am I doing?
Oh!
I hold up.
I power up.
Pshh!
Oh my god!
I might cry when we see him.
Oh!
Cute!
It's a water slide!
Wait!
There we go!
Wait, did I get everything?
You think I got everything, you guys?
No coins left behind?
Sorry, I'm a bit of a hoarder.
I must collect everything?
Oi!
Here we go!
Oh gosh, the turtle's chasing after me!
Baby girl!
Thanks for the ball, I'm gifted.
What's going on in here?
How do I dive?
Um...
Oh, there we go.
Just jump in.
Jump on in, the water's fine.
The water's good.
Best water slide.
That was nice.
Oh!
I'm powering up!
Oooh!
Ah!
Oh!
Did this just say secret?
Wait!
That's right.
Oh my gosh, wait!
I think I have to...
There we go.
Yeah!
Shake your booty!
Yeah?
Multiversal rebel.
A Lombax from another dimension?
Riveting!
Rivet.
I like playing with them.
It's pretty fun.
Alright, cool.
Oi!
Rivet.
Riveting.
What is rivet from?
Is it also Ratchet and Clank?
I actually haven't played that series, so...
Um...
Oh!
Hold on, these guys are...
Ruining the mood!
Get out of here.
Oh!
A one...
A two!
They're fun, you know?
Would recommend.
This is so cute.
Look at our little guy!
He's so cute!
He's just running all around!
Oh!
Hold
on, we'll get...
Wow!
Yeah, that's right.
You think you can mess with my money?
What about Jak and Daxter?
Actually, I never played that one either.
Yeah, I never played that one either.
Actually.
This guy, he's also ruining the mood.
Oi!
I
think I jump and...
Do I jump over...
Okay, no.
I think I...
Maybe I do jump over.
This is a big old taco!
Is there a guy in here?
They were trying to bury him alive, for real.
What?
Wait, what?
Oh!
I didn't know it was that kind of game.
Wait, so...
Can I still attack Lime?
Oh, come on!
Grab it!
Yeah!
We got it!
It's like Kirby.
I was gonna say...
But Kirby makes like a cuter noise.
But I was thinking of actually...
What's his name?
Um...
Oh my gosh!
I keep...
Sorry, I'm so tired.
I keep wanting to say Luigi!
But that's not who!
Yoshi!
Wait, can I climb up this?
Can I grab this and climb?
Um, Yoshi!
You know how Yoshi goes...
Can I wall jump?
Okay, I have to...
I have to inflate.
Oh yeah, that skill that I just learned, right?
I don't actually...
I don't remember what sound...
I should probably be punching these trees, huh?
Um...
Uh...
Kirby makes.
Oh!
Gosh!
There's so much hidden in here!
For real!
Is this a boss?
Oh no!
I think it's a boss!
Oh!
Alright, here we go!
Maybe?
Oh!
Who's in here?
Ah!
You're welcome!
I know, I'm so good at my job.
I'm gonna punch you.
Get in my controller.
Get in my controller so I can...
Bobble you around.
Yeah!
Yeah, you like that?
Ooh!
Oh my gosh!
Eww!
Do you see how it's like...
So jelly!
Delicious!
Oh!
So yummy!
Okay.
I'm glad we're a robot.
We don't have to breathe.
What's in here though?
Giant shadows that I'm seeing.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of them.
Here we go!
We're gonna go up!
We're gonna go up towards the shadows!
Oh!
Chat,
don't back, Xander.
Yeah, if I miss stuff, that's okay.
It's my first time playing, you know?
I'm not gonna get everything.
That's a-okay, baby.
Third piece!
Woo!
I don't know what that means, but...
Probably means I'm really good at this game.
Except snake.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yahoo!
Woohoo!
How dare you make mistakes, VTuber!
Um, but I do wanna...
Is it a game where...
If you don't collect all the bots...
Like, you collect all the bots, right?
What's going on in here?
Oh, wait.
Oh!
I think I just...
Oh, I missed a guy!
Wait.
Hold on.
Yeah.
I gotta get the...
I missed a man!
We can't go through there yet!
Hold on.
Um...
Where was he?
That's what we were saying, yeah.
I mean, like I said...
I'm gonna miss some stuff.
It's okay.
Um...
Is there fall damage?
Oh, it actually won't let me.
Okay, let's go back in.
Maybe down here?
Oh, no, no, no!
I'm punching everything?
Is he in the logs?
Is he in this chicken?
Is he up there?
I see nothing.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Well, there's...
Eww!
This cranium.
Uh...
Well, anyways.
It's a good thing I came over here.
So I can get all the coins.
At least.
Yeah, I hate...
...petals.
Yeah, I hate... This place is...
...too beautiful.
Need to ugly it up a little bit.
You're hoarding all the...
...beautiful petals for yourselves.
It's not very kind of you.
I think there's something up on this tree.
And I think...
...it's our...
...little guy!
Oh!
There's another one!
There's another...
Oh my gosh.
Fly higher!
Oh wait, I think I know what to do.
Astro what?
Okay, here we go.
And then from here...
...we float!
Yeah!
Oh!
Um...
There we go!
I'm kind of a genius.
If I have to say so myself.
Look at the...
...like the blurring of the background.
Okay, where the heck is this guy?
Am I blind?
Where is he?
Little guy!
It's just the first level, please.
Be really obvious.
Yeah, I'm blind!
Can you guys give me a hint?
In the water with the turtle?
Oh!
He's right...
He was swimming!
Of course I didn't notice him.
Alright, get in there.
There we go.
I was too busy paying attention to the turtle!
Alright.
Now we're good.
That guy was living his best life actually.
I don't think we rescued him at all.
He looked like he was really enjoying himself.
He wasn't in danger at all!
In fact, he seemed perfectly fine.
Yeah, I'm ruining their day for real.
Alrighty.
Now, we can continue onward.
Yippee!
Here
we go into... whatever this thing is.
Oh wait, before we do that...
Secret door.
Nothing.
Here.
Okay.
Yeah, this is our land now.
Yeah, stupid fish.
Planet conquered.
Was he just flossing?
What's that?
Wait, what's that?
Oh.
I didn't think I was gonna blast off like crazy like that.
You know what?
That's okay.
Do we want to go to Ice Cream World or do we want to go to Aztec Trail?
Creamy Canyon.
Ice cream?
I scream?
You scream?
We all scream for ice cream!
Aztec looks very crash.
Yes, it does.
What if I just miss the landing?
Nevermind.
I never miss.
Oh.
Oh!
Hi!
Oh.
There's balls everywhere.
I have to dig for treasure and stuff.
Nom nom nom.
I can't believe it.
Nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom nom...
I wanna eat all of this!
Is that...
through my eyes?
Come here.
Come here you're...
Come here you're... Come here!
Come
here!
Come here!
Wait, where is he?
Oh there he is.
Come out!
Snake, come out!
Get out of your cage!
Get out of your cage, Snake!
Come here.
I just wanna look at you.
No, don't hide from me!
Don't hide from me!
I'm good.
I'm calm.
Don't hide.
It's okay.
He's so cute.
Can I dump him out?
Come out.
Snake.
Get out of there.
Snake, open up.
Let me into your heart.
Look, he's waving at me!
Come out.
Okay.
Was a terrible child is such a good tag.
Stop traumatizing him!
You're scaring him.
Oh no!
Our bot's cold!
What's this?
Yeah!
Oh, what's this?
Oh!
Fine.
Okay, so we gotta get... See?
It's good that...
I'm eating everything.
Oh, I gotta push him over.
Push.
Push him into here.
There we go!
Okay, but first...
The music slowed down.
Oh, okay.
I'm eating.
Gotta eat everything, you guys.
You never know.
Where did our ship go?
I'm basically just mowing the lawn.
If you think about it.
What's up there?
Oh, wait!
Wait, can I get you back out?
Can you come here?
Real quick?
Hey, stop bullying him!
Oh, I wanna go up there.
I missed my opportunity.
Dang it.
Stop bullying him kills him?
He...
He was a wimp.
What can I say?
Psycho
Mantis!
Wait, give it back!
Give it back!
Give back Psycho Mantis!
You knew
Metal Gear was here.
You guys know me so well.
You know me so well.
I know we're like trying to get to you.
Oops.
Oh my gosh.
Platforming time!
Okay, now we have to like actually get him.
Look at him go!
I just wanted some ice cream.
Stop being so tsundere, you guys.
Stop being
so tsundere, you guys.
Look at them together.
Snake's enjoying it though.
He's like...
Oh, sorry.
They're so cute!
Oh my gosh.
What is Snake doing actually?
Why is he thrusting his hips like that?
Come out.
Come on.
Get out of there.
Guys, I think I'm enjoying this game a little too much.
I think I'm having a little bit too much fun.
What
are those?
There's mushrooms.
And they glow.
I'm not done clearing the land.
You can flip once I'm telling you to.
You can't!
Snow mushrooms.
Mint.
That's me!
Hello!
I feel like I missed some stuff over here though, right?
We were so preoccupied with...
Wait!
I can get to it from here, can't I?
Probably.
Okay, I hope I don't die!
How
can I check?
I guess I still have him because...
Because I don't see him being flown around.
Oops.
What?
Press S?
Oh!
No!
Skip!
Oh!
Options.
There he is.
I accidentally pressed the...
The playstation...
The big button in the middle.
See, these look breakable, right?
What do you mean?
You think now I'll make it?
Yeah.
Probably.
From here.
Nevermind.
Maybe off the ladybug?
Maybe the ladybug...
Is the key.
No!
I have to re-clear everything.
Okay, let's try off the ladybug.
Ooh!
Okay.
Ladybug, come here.
Ladybug, get closer to the edge.
Ladybug?
Oh!
Okay, ladybug?
I'm gonna push you, like, right there.
Oh.
Ladybug, don't leave me.
Okay, ladybug?
Ladybug?
Oh.
I think there's a wall!
POV your cat noir.
I'm a lady.
Almost.
I can't tell if there's a wall or if I'm just bad.
Could be.
Both?
The first ladybug?
Because he's trapped in that hole.
Actually, can I get him out of that hole?
I don't know.
I don't think I can.
Let's see.
I thought he was trapped in there.
What is this?
They're in love with me!
Oh my god, so cute!
I just noticed we have, like, a little cave.
So cute!
Cute!
Ah!
Oh, I'm trapped?
Okay, there we go.
See ya!
Oh, move, please.
I'd say that was worth it.
Ah!
I think that was worth it.
Okay, now we can continue on working.
This song reminds me of, like, an idol song.
Like, I could hear it being performed by an idol group.
Oh,
wait!
They cleared this whole area!
Aw, man.
We're gonna use him to help us.
You'll get up when I tell you to.
Now be a good girl and sit there.
Okay.
Oh, Piggy!
Woo!
I think I have to destroy him a different way.
Or I don't wake him up.
I can't see him!
A butt!
Oh, maybe I need him to destroy this thing.
Come here, come here!
Wait!
He's got a butt!
He came back!
And he spooked me!
How do I...
How do I take care of this part?
Spin on the glowy spot?
Oh,
like this!
Ah!
One of these things is not like the other.
One of these guys just doesn't belong!
Oh, wait, I need you.
Actually, come over here.
I need you, I need you.
Wake up.
Come here, come here.
Just a butt.
Eva, I need you.
Let him
do his thing then.
Forever.
Why is there a ladybug here?
Oh!
Oh, cute!
Oh my gosh!
I can create such beautiful boobs.
Figure eight.
I was asked today if anything makes me happy.
I answered thusly, Minto.
What do you mean by that?
Oh, I'm stuck.
Wait.
Oh, that...
Oh
my gosh, that was so close.
I almost didn't get it.
Oh, he got him to break it!
Wait!
No!
Wow!
I think there was one...
I think there was also a gray fox.
I think.
I wonder if he's in this level two then.
I wonder if gray fox is here.
I think those are the three metal gears in this...
in this game.
I don't remember if there's any more, to be honest.
Actually, if I go down here...
Oh, there's a ladder.
I was like, how do I get back up?
There are more?
For real?
Speak of the devil.
Yeah, more than three?
No way.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited then.
I only know of the three of them.
So...
Whoa!
Oh
my gosh, it's...
It's just havoc.
It's chaos.
It's... Oh my god.
We're destroying everything.
I'll get you, gray fox!
After Zanzibar!
I was taken from the battlefield!
Neither truly alive.
Nor truly dead.
Oh my god.
He's wiggling his butt in front of me.
What are you...
Are you asking me to smack your butt?
Gray fox?
Oh my god.
He wants me to tap that ass.
I mean, if you insist.
I mean, Astro Bot looks really excited to do so also.
Do you notice he's like...
He's like ready to...
He's ready to do it.
Alright, here we go.
We're in prime ass punching position.
Here we go.
Hurt him more.
Hurt me more, snake!
Look at them!
Neither enemy nor friend!
Mystery ninja!
Look, they're all so happy.
He's just sitting there.
Everybody else is like...
He's just...
He's just staring at the camera.
Gray fox, are you okay?
He's so traumatized.
Do something!
Are you alive?
Hello!
I think you broke him.
I think so too.
These guys are camping me.
Let's get out of here.
Hurt me more, snake.
Wait, I didn't notice.
Have we gotten all the...
All the guys so far?
We haven't missed one, right?
Good.
That's where I need you.
We're missing one, but...
But...
No, I missed one!
Oh, check with the button.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, towards the beginning!
Look at Snake.
He looks so happy there.
Wait, I missed a guy.
Okay, well, the second one...
The last one is probably up there, right?
Oh my gosh, that's a big guy.
Okay, hold on.
We missed some.
Hmm...
What are those guys doing on the ice right there?
Do you see them?
Are they supposed to be there?
Okay, so it's in between Snake and Psycho Mantis.
So...
He's gotta be around that way.
Check the second floor basement.
Second floor basement?
Oh!
So cute.
Hmm...
Oh, maybe like a...
There's some stuff up here though that we...
Oh!
Ah!
Oh man!
Wait!
Was it a...
Oh, I think I had to like wait.
Okay.
Until it turned gold.
I didn't realize it was like...
Spinning around.
I wanna get up there, but...
Do you think if I go through here...
Oh!
Is this my second shot?
There we go.
Okay, let's try this again.
Hey!
Oh!
Ah!
Okay.
Whoa!
Wow, we get a lot.
Okay.
The ice seal?
Yeah, I think he's probably in there, right?
That would make the most sense, but I tried beating it up.
Hmm...
This pig's gonna show back up again.
Ow!
What did I...
I thought I saw something jump out of here.
I think that's just the checkpoint guy.
Try the pig?
Oh!
Gui!
Buhi!
Boop boop boop boop boop boop!
You guys are kinda geniuses, I think.
Oh, disco party!
Wow, there's actual ice cream in here!
Oh!
Apples?
On my ice cream?
That's me!
Oh!
Oh.
This one looks like takoyaki.
Yummy.
Takoyaki.
Anything else I can see?
We're partying on the disco ball.
Takoyaki.
Wait, what is this?
This seems like a conclusion.
What's going on?
Huh?
Lost galaxy?
Washroom.
Funky fungi!
I guess we gotta go.
I wasn't done with that world though.
I swear it's the other guy!
Everybody watch out!
Watch out!
Thank
you!
Are you a fungi, Mint?
Yeah?
I'm a mushroom.
The dolphins.
I just wanna be part of your symphony!
Oh!
Hmm...
Yeah, you think you're so tough.
You think.
You thought.
Oh, I have to...
Oh, that's right.
I do.
Oh, wait.
I think I do it on here.
Okay, yeah.
I saw that.
Not a very good disguise, if you tell me.
Yikes!
Thanks for the tag, Giften!
Whoa!
Wow!
Who is that?
Oh my gosh.
Astro, what?
Who is this?
I guess we gotta punch him to find out.
Bot rescued!
Vampire killer?
Castlevania?
John Castlevania?
It's...
Wait!
It's Richter Belmont!
Ha ha ha ha!
Comes from a long line of Candle Smashers.
Whoa!
We're gonna get Castlevania guys here!
There's so many fun...
Oh, sorry.
What is this thing supposed to be?
Hey.
Explain yourself.
What is your existence?
Are you a cricket?
Oh, it's a cricket.
Yeah.
There's a snake.
It's a little slithery snake.
Oh, hold on.
I don't know how to swing.
And jump!
This looks mysterious.
Guess it's nothing.
It's kind of swirly, right?
Like it should be something there.
Not so solid snake.
Goodness.
Nasty.
Before we continue onwards, I'm going to keep checking this to make sure we don't miss any people.
First time watching you, you didn't disappoint.
Thanks for the third Super Chat with your first time watching!
Thank you!
Oh, what is...
Oh, okay.
So there's going to be a spiky guy and also...
Wait!
No!
I gotta get this guy.
Ow!
I blew myself up.
I missed my...
There we go.
Ah, come on!
Nasty!
There we go.
Now how do I throw?
Square!
Did I throw it?
Oh, no.
And... square!
That's why the...
That's why the mushrooms were glowy!
In the ice cream world!
It was a sign!
It's the fun guys.
Are we so sure about that?
Hahaha.
I see this.
Don't worry.
I'm not that blind.
Okay.
That's what that does.
Understood.
Yesha!
Oh, wait.
Uh...
This...
Yeah.
No!
Ta-da!
Little...
Oh, it's these guys!
Yeah!
You thought.
Yeah,
get his butt.
Yesha!
There's so many places we can go.
I'm like...
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
There's so many places we can go to.
Wait!
Song is nice.
I know, right?
Alright.
Yarnim Tourist.
Destined for greatness.
Who term is Bloodborne?
Ah!
John Bloodborne.
I gotta...
I'm gonna play that soon, you guys.
Gonna be playing that soon.
I think we got everything up here then.
Hahaha.
I...
Oh.
Do-do-do-do-do-do.
Darn.
Okay.
I think we got everything up here.
Oh, gosh!
Wow!
Get away from me!
Sometimes it sounds like he's going, shoobah-shoobah-shoobah-shoobah!
Oh, I missed every...
You missed every shot you take, you guys.
Those words to live by.
Okay?
A fungobot!
Get it?
Because he's got fungus on him.
But he's a bot.
Get it?
Like a funcopop, but he's a fungobot.
You get it?
It's a good joke.
But that was negative to me!
I'm gonna go the other way.
I don't know if it's any different or not, but I feel like it could be.
Maybe it wasn't different at all.
Oh my gosh!
Ow!
Wait, how far behind are we?
Oh, okay.
Not that far.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay, I'm glad that even though there's like checkpoints, the checkpoints are only for...
Wait, what's this?
Did I go down here?
I did not go down here.
They're only for like where you respawn.
This one.
How's it go?
Oh!
There we go!
I was gonna say that one felt weird.
The vibration.
Yeah!
They're clapping at me!
They were like, wow!
I think Minto is a genius for real.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Yeah.
Get it.
Wait, these are actual...
Wait!
Yippee!
Easy.
I'm high-fiving the crowd right now.
I'm high-fiving the crowd.
High-five!
Hi-five!
Hai-five!
High-five!
Hi-five!
That's our victory lap.
When he spins, it says gururukuru.
It means he spins.
Wait, he does?
I didn't hear him say that.
I know gururukuru means spin.
Couldn't hear him say it, though.
Oh that!
Gururukuru!
Oh wait, it's not over yet...
Come on!
Secret!
Is that it?
Do I go down?
Oh!
Gross!
Let me wash myself.
Oh!
Look how cute he is!
He's so cute.
Oh!
Gross!
Nasty!
Alucard!
Thank you!
The name backwards!
No, it's Dracula backwards.
Dandidampire!
Dampire.
The total opposite of his father.
Literally!
Look at them.
They're partying.
So crazy.
Wait, I forgot to check.
Okay, we have just one guy left.
And then we're good.
Do we go down here?
Did you know Alucard is backwards as Hunter?
Okay, we can't go down there.
Good to know.
Okay,
we're back here.
Very good.
Bye!
Okay.
This rock looks suspicious.
I think.
Oh my god.
Oh no, not this.
Pull his ass!
David, thanks for the time gifted!
Raid?
I don't ever see the raid messages.
Thank you for the raid!
Yay!
YouTube is so broken.
Hello, hello, hello!
I'm playing Astro Bot.
And it's really cute.
I'm totally normal.
How cute this game is.
It's actually so cute.
Wait, can I go around here?
Oh, no.
I could...
I hear someone crying.
I hear someone...
begging for their life.
Where are they?
I hear them begging for their life!
Ducky, thanks for the gift!
Oh my god, there's so much more up there even.
Okay, maybe he's up top.
I thought this was like the end of the road.
I think we have to defeat this guy.
Oh my gosh.
That was easy.
Yeah, there he is, there he is, there he is!
Okay.
We got him, we got him, we got him.
Oh, Jack, thank you for the 20 gift!
AX, thanks for the 5 gift!
Oh, hold on.
How do I...
How do I do this?
Wait, can I use the...
this to go up here?
No, it doesn't go up high enough.
This is my 25th birthday this weekend!
Happy birthday!
I already had a quarter life crisis.
But can my fave Stinky Mates see me?
Happy birthday.
Yes!
Don't have a quarter life crisis.
Instead, have a half life crisis.
Full life consequences.
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Adobo!
I'm not Stinky Mate!
Happy birthday!
C2!
Thanks for the 5 gift!
Jack is out!
Thanks for the 20 gift!
Thank you guys!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Ay-yasha!
Hmm...
I feel like I have to use this to get up here, but...
Maybe I just have to time it better.
Whaaaaat?
How do I get up there?
There must be another way.
Maybe I jump up on the top of here.
It is a little bit angled.
Alright...
Oh!
Ah!
Maybe, maybe...
Okay, hold on, hold on.
The second one...
Let me try this one more time.
Try princess!
Thanks for the 5...
gift!
Okay, I'll go to this then.
But it just puts me further away.
That's why I was like, I don't know if it's this one.
I just go really far away.
Sment.
Flamo.
Oh, maybe that stone right there.
I do see it.
Sment.
Weee!
Hold on.
This one right here, right?
Yeah, yeah.
This seems to be the one.
How dare!
You want me to slap your butt?
Family.
A little family.
Kiss himself!
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you!
Okay.
Now that we did that, we can continue onward.
Oh, just kidding.
I have to make the platform before we do that.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
I did not think he was going to be able to reach that far.
Okay.
Oh my god!
I don't think he can destroy this one!
But I can get flattened.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
I can get flattened though.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
We
had him!
So...
I nearly had him.
I'm going to go back and get it.
My coin!
I really want to play this game.
Just to see my Oshii John Ace Combat.
Wait!
Ace Combat is in this too!
Oh my god.
Wow, it's beautiful.
Oh, they're so cute!
The soundtrack in this game is so good.
This game is so cute!
This guy...
He's like, What are you waiting for?
Get out of my home!
You've caused enough havoc!
You've destroyed everything!
All of my lifelong work!
Please leave!
Yeah!
Why is he British?
I don't know.
Gets British energy.
Here we go!
Oh!
Okay, hold on.
Wow!
I did it this time.
Woo!
Our home planet.
Yay!
World Conq.
Wait.
Oh!
I missed a puzzle piece!
I love the silly ghost of me.
Thanks for the super turret!
Can you change your astrobot to snake?
Can I?
Go back.
Secrets.
Here?
Crash sound.
Wheeew!
Good morning!
Oh!
Whoa!
Our civilization!
Oh my gosh!
We're taking over this planet too!
Hahaha!
Wait.
No!
Why is Graybot...
Why are they all flossing!
You rescued your first bot!
Many more scattered across the universe.
So search every planet and try to rescue them all!
Oh!
This is what we're collecting the pieces for!
Oh my god.
They just saluted me.
Wait.
Snake, come back.
Snake!
Snake, come here.
Snake.
Why are you guys running the furthest away?
Oh my god.
Snake.
Hahaha!
Oh my god.
Look at him like...
Do you see him sitting there?
Look at him like bouncing up and down like that.
Hahaha!
He hurt me more!
Snake!
Hahaha!
What's the little symbol by them?
What is this?
Hahaha!
It's gotcha!
You can get special animations for them later?
What is this pee-pee music?
Oh!
A puzzle piece.
I need to sacrifice 10.
Snake!
Wait, where are they going?
What the?
Go!
Oh, here I go!
I'm going too!
You can...
You can let go.
Maybe if I run away.
Maybe if I run away they...
Okay.
Return to your position!
Hahaha!
You stupid...
Sorry, I didn't mean to...
I didn't mean to...
punch you.
It hurts me more...
mental.
Oh, we need stuff for that.
Oh my gosh.
This game is giving me so much energy.
Oh!
Yippee!
Changing room?
It's under construction.
I need to sacrifice 10 bots.
Nine bots.
Here we go!
Heave ho, everybody!
Heave ho!
Oh, me too.
I guess I should put in the work.
You need to help.
Capable!
What are you talking about?
Hahaha!
Hey, everybody!
Hey, all you people.
Won't you listen to me?
Okay,
I got it.
We're done.
See, look how capable they are.
The changing room is where you can dress...
a snake?
Wait, I already did this one.
Why is it telling me to do it again?
Interesting.
I feel like you'd be a terrible boss.
What are you talking about?
You guys...
I'm a great boss.
I run a maid cafe.
That's why you guys call me boss.
Right?
Oh my gosh.
We must free them.
Hurry!
Snake!
They're dead!
Bot rescue.
Oh, we actually got some more.
That's crazy.
Okay, I'm jumping on.
I'm climbing you.
Oh, snake.
Snake.
He's shaking his head.
He's like, don't do it.
Snake.
Sorry, I don't mean to harass you.
Oh, hold on.
I gotta do it again.
Sorry, my bad.
I'm not just doing this on purpose or anything.
Snake.
Yay!
Are you okay?
What's getting you so excited?
He'll come back.
He'll come back, right?
Do not punch the guys.
What are they doing?
They're fighting.
The girls are fighting.
Are you guys okay?
What's going on?
What's happening?
Go home.
They're terrified of what?
Miss the war crime.
No, no, no, no, no.
He'll come back.
I rescued him.
What is this thing?
Oh.
Why isn't it now letting me go to the next page?
Oh, R1.
My bad.
I was pressing R2.
Oh, there they are.
Hehe.
Look at him.
He stands so proud.
Oh my gosh.
He got his little hair thing.
His little hair blips.
Wait, they gave him side...
Like, wicked sideburns.
Look at that.
Does MGS1 Snake have sideburns?
Rookus!
Thanks for the time gifter.
Thank you.
Woohoo.
Oh my gosh.
Wow!
Oh my god.
It looks so good.
Looks so good.
Don't be doco.
What are you talking about?
It's there, baby.
Oh my god.
Psycho Mantis looks so cute though.
He looks really...
Like...
When you see his outfit...
He looks kind of...
This guy doesn't wear shoes.
What a freak.
I know!
He looks really freaky.
Can't achieve anything?
He puts his mind to psychic menace.
What a menace.
Oh my gosh.
The underside is so cute too.
There's so much attention to detail here.
Why are you...
Why are you doing that?
Why are you doing that motion?
Why is he thrusting?
Vampire killer.
He looks sassy.
His eyes.
So cute.
Classy.
Oh look it.
Ratchet.
Oh my gosh.
So cute.
Oh they look so cute.
Oh my gosh.
Even like the smudge marks on the back of the little robot.
Wow.
It looks so good.
Cute.
So cute.
So happy.
Yeah.
Psycho Mantis actually helped us.
I know.
Oh wait.
And then we have Blood Board Man.
None of them are wearing shoes, huh?
Look at the detail on his hat.
It looks like real leather.
Wow.
The texture on his coat.
There's so much detail put into these little guys.
I'm so excited.
Nice.
Oh we just need two guys here.
Oh and me?
There's so many puzzle pieces just in this one spot.
The music here is so epic.
The chorus.
Oh my gosh.
I want the soundtrack to this game.
This sounds so good.
So
clearly we have more areas.
But let's go back to our spaceship.
Clank is also voiced by Beasties Megatron in this show movie, eh?
No way!
Beasties.
I love Beast Wars.
Okay.
Let's go!
Beasties.
Should we go back to where we came from?
We were in the monkey world.
Which one was the planet that we didn't finish?
This one.
Ice cream.
You scream.
We're all screaming because we're gonna crash!
200 coins for what?
Wait.
Somebody.
What is this?
Don't touch me.
A guide?
A bird?
A pet?
What?
Look!
There's one in here!
I don't think we noticed this one before.
Oh.
Hold on.
Come here.
There we go.
Nice!
Hint bird?
Oh.
He's like...
No.
Hold on.
I'm trying to... I'm trying to...
No.
I'm trying to get him in the hole.
Why is it so hard?
What was this one again?
Oh.
The puzzle piece we already got.
But we get more coins for it.
Okay.
That's enough.
So the...
This guy has got to be around here somewhere.
Yeah.
The bird was hinting at below.
Oh.
That was close.
Like he was like...
At the wall, right?
Here.
Yeah.
Here at the wall.
Wait.
I just noticed.
Maybe there.
Oh.
Okay.
Good.
Perfect.
Then we just have the last...
I don't even think we beat the level.
So... technically.
Like we...
Didn't even get it to the very end.
So let's go do that.
Jinja!
Welcome back for two months.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Thank you so much!
There!
Now eat the bird.
No, he's gonna help us still.
Just a little bit.
Probably.
Oh, that's nice.
So you can just keep coming back to these.
And like...
Oh.
I've got...
You!
You can just keep coming back and like farming coins.
I could use some ice cream.
Mmm.
Wait.
Oh!
I think we're gonna go in.
Going in was what made us go into a different dimension.
Right?
It wasn't going in what made us go to the mushroom world.
No need to dig?
Okay.
What about here?
This was also where we discovered somebody.
Yeah!
There's a lot of coins in here.
Why not?
We're here.
Yeah!
Okay, bye.
It's okay.
We don't have to go through there.
Wee!
Is
that my bird talking?
Or...
Someone is...
Oh, there's a bird up there chirping.
Okay.
There's that bird right there.
Yeah!
Hahaha.
So much ladybug bullying.
Ladybugs scare me, so...
I don't mind it so much.
Hahaha.
Sorry, Barry.
Oh my god!
Oh, he just murdered that guy!
Oh my god.
The pig ate the bot.
The pig ate the bot!
Oh my god.
Where did you guys come from?
Yeah!
Oh, there he is!
Help me!
We got him.
Astro Bot looks so fun.
This game is actually so fun.
Boing!
All
of our guys...
Oh my god, Snake, what are you doing?
Oh my god, Psychobat, what are you doing?
Oh, okay.
Snake's like, come on!
Come on!
Meow!
Hold on tight, Grayfaw!
Really?
That bird?
That bird cheated me.
Hahaha.
That bird cheated me!
What?
Okay, let's go to this place.
Wahoo!
Knock
knock!
Oh!
Oh wait, I feel it.
There, this one.
Wait.
This...
Oh, I push.
I just push it.
Hahaha.
Hmm.
Interesting.
What about you, bird?
Thank you.
I like the door's design.
Yeah!
It's so cool.
Put him in top...
Put him in here.
I got you!
They turn around!
They literally turn around!
And wait to get slapped!
They're just like...
Yeah!
Come here!
Maboot!
Wow!
All the leaves!
So cool!
Hahaha.
Maboot!
They sound like Blue from Blue's Clues.
Sorry, little geckos.
So awesome!
Who is it?
It's not who.
I've got...
I've got chompers.
What?
What do they do?
Awesome.
Never mind.
Oh!
Yes, mind!
I was correct.
We gotta look around everywhere.
Make sure we're getting everything, you guys.
Oh!
Hahaha.
I just did something.
I don't know what that just did, actually.
Ah!
The little monkey!
Hahaha.
Freaky ghost maid.
That's my name.
That frog.
Sorry.
Where did those birds go?
Oh!
Bless you.
Thank you!
I used to never be able to...
I used to never be able to sneeze on stream.
Now, recently I've only been...
Oh, not streaming.
Sneezing.
Nice!
Let's do this one first.
Okay.
Wait!
Whoever said it was like Crash?
You were so right!
Why was...
Wait, Snake was probably on the ice cream because Shadow Moses is in Alaska!
And then...
Oh my god!
It makes sense!
And also because he's obsessed with me because I'm Mint!
Yay!
We got Crash!
Spinning marsupial.
Not to be confused with a naughty dog.
That was like straight up him though.
That wasn't even like a...
Like he didn't even look like a bot.
It just looked like him, you know?
I can't tell if we can go to these other highlands or not.
Maybe not.
Okay.
Onwards!
Forwards!
Oh neat!
What's this?
You're welcome!
I'm so benevolent.
Okay, we need this.
Oh, maybe...
Okay, hold on.
Probably to take down...
Probably to get that up there, right?
Yeah!
We
already missed a guy!
Oh my god!
I was gonna say, so far so good!
I was literally two seconds away from being like Alright!
So far so good!
How the heck?
Who did we miss?
In here?
No, this is...
Look at these little lizards.
Love them.
That guy was there.
I need a hint bird.
You think he's...
Maybe...
No, stop it!
Inside his teeth?
He's near crash?
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
Near crash, eh?
Near crash...
He's like dangling for his life.
Wait, did I just hear a guy?
Did I just hear a guy?
Did that again?
Like how near crash are we talking?
I
think I'm going crazy.
I think I'm going crazy.
I see a box there, but I don't see a guy.
A waterfall?
Well, let's get that box first.
Oh
my gosh, he's in here!
You sneaky!
You're so sneaky!
Nice.
Okay, now we can continue onward.
Well, I should start checking more periodically.
Oh, oops.
Otherwise, I'll forget.
Okay.
Next Minto panel at a con, everyone is going to floss in front of you.
Don't say that.
That's so rude.
Nice.
What is this thing?
Oh,
it's a Matryoshka doll!
Cute.
Floss for the boss.
No!
The boss does not wish this on you!
You gotta put the freak phantom glasses on, ma'am.
Why?
What did I do this time?
What's going on?
That's right.
Slap your butt.
Donations feel a little delayed.
I think they are.
It's because there was a bunch of gifted membership.
Up...
Wow.
First try, baby.
Oh.
Up.
The crowd goes mild.
Oh my God.
I'll get you out of there.
How do I get you out of there?
There we go.
Stop horsing around.
I'm actually having a thank you for the Five-Gifted.
Thank you.
Yo, big boss man.
As a fellow gamer, what's your take on the PS5 Pro?
And the ridiculous price of $700.
Also, no describe and stand.
What are you talking about?
There's a stand?
You just gotta pay 30 extra dollars for it.
That was an announcement.
That was an announcement, wasn't it, you guys?
All
things, you know...
Whoops, sorry, I wasn't really paying attention.
All jokes aside, I know that there's not so much on the PS5.
And maybe that's being kind about it.
But also, I'm really excited to play Delta on it.
So...
And quite honestly, I...
Okay, this is...
Oh my gosh, I'm so embarrassed to admit this.
I wasn't gonna admit this, okay?
I wasn't going to admit this.
But I've...
I...
I thought...
I thought Delta was gonna...
I thought it was gonna be a PS5 exclusive for some reason.
I made that up in my brain.
And so I was like, oh, well, I gotta get it.
But now I can play this game.
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Whoa.
Wait.
Ow.
Oh.
Oh, that was close.
That was close.
What is over here?
There's something...
There's gotta be something up there.
There's gotta be something there.
But, you know...
It's fine.
It's fine, though.
It's all good.
As for the pro...
I have this, so I don't need it.
And it's also a lot of money.
How
I can get up there?
He's so scary in there.
It's a bunch of regular guns.
Guys.
And then just Crash Bandicoot staring at me like that Smile movie.
It looks so creepy.
The platform?
Oh, my God.
Is it good?
Wait.
That wasn't...
Okay.
Good.
We just have one more guy.
Oh, gosh.
Oh.
That was...
That was close.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
I wasn't ready for that.
I wasn't ready.
Oh.
Somehow I made it.
Why did it get so dark?
Someone's slowly making their way through the MGS1 on...
Through MGS1 on the Master Collection.
Would it be better to play the OG Snake either first or just play Delta?
I think...
You...
You could do whichever one you wanted, to be honest, actually.
I'm wanting to punch this thing here.
Oh.
Oops.
I'm wanting to punch...
This here.
Oh.
Okay.
Never mind.
It doesn't do anything.
I thought it might.
Worth a shot.
Okay.
Um...
According to some wisps, you should start at the...
Those wisps are raw.
That's what I do to those wisps.
Oh.
Okay.
I give them the old...
One-two!
Wait a second.
Oh.
Okay.
That's where we got that.
Just kidding.
Woo-hoo.
Monkeys...
Whoa.
Monkey...
Monkeys...
Oh, monkeys.
Um.
I'm gonna...
Um...
Excuse me.
Ugh.
Uh.
Oh my gosh, that was close.
There we go.
Okay, we got it.
If you
play the OG, the original 3 first, you might appreciate it a bit more.
You know what I mean?
If you're going through and then you could...
What's in here?
Secret...
Oh...
Oh my god!
Oh
gosh!
Oh gosh, okay.
Okay, we got this.
Alright!
Okay!
That was so close!
Okay, how do I do this then?
Oh my gosh, I see him up there!
It's Jack!
Right?
From Jack and...
Wait, yeah, Jack and... It's Jack!
Jack and Daxter!
Jacks?
Jacks and Dax?
Wait, Jack?
It's Jack, right?
I see him right there!
He looks so scared!
Wait, oh gosh.
How do I do this part?
Okay.
That was so close!
Dang it, I have to do the whole thing over again.
Okay, we got this.
We got this.
Secret...
This one's hard.
Luckily, it's not so hard to get back to it, but...
It's... maybe...
Yeah, I think you can land on the red beam.
I think so too.
Yeah!
I just have to be careful.
Punch!
Yeah!
Eco Warrior left a legacy worthy of the precursors.
There he is.
He's just in there, looking so cute.
Why is Crash so scary looking?
He's like eating his body right now.
Oh god.
What did they do to you, Crash?
Okie dokie.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go, baby.
Here we go.
The monkeys are excited.
The monkeys are excited for us.
Oh my gosh.
Don't just cheer, you guys!
You sickos!
Yeah!
Kicked his butt!
We wiped his butt, everybody.
We wiped it.
We wiped the floor with his butt.
Let's go!
Oh my god, Crash is flossing.
How...
What did we do on this planet?
No!
What did we miss?
We missed the puzzle pieces.
That's okay.
We don't have to get everything.
First try, you know.
Puzzle pieces.
The puzzle pieces.
And it said that there was a warp.
Get that!
Oh, avoid that!
Get...
Get that!
Avoid that!
Oh my gosh, I like how there's an intro.
Or like a...
I like that there's a little...
Like mini-game kind of thing when you come in too.
Oops, sorry.
Sorry.
Destruction's over.
Wait till you see the boss?
Wait, what do you mean?
Oh!
April 30th!
Is that a bad guy?
Like he's got his fist up ready?
Ready for fighting?
Okay.
Oh no!
What's wrong with you?
I like how he says thank you.
They're so polite.
They're so cute.
You think there's a guy in there?
I gotta watch out for the...
The ghoul.
We are killing it, you guys.
We're killing it and we're also killing things.
Oh!
I don't know what I'm creating.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
There was just that guy.
Oh, the buildings are pink.
They're so cute.
Killing all the birds with stone.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay.
He's like, whoa, calm down, buddy.
What are you gonna do?
Whoa!
Oh my god!
They're like, we just built this.
What's wrong with you?
How do I get over there?
Just jump?
Thank you.
Our power.
What do we get?
A dog!
What does he do?
Cute.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Distraction!
Splatoon!
Oh my god, so cute.
I'm just gonna walk by this guy's real cat.
Ew!
Oh my gosh.
I wanna make some... I wanna get something into the...
Maybe if I...
Oh!
Oh, dang it!
If I had punched him...
Into the...
Okay, hold on.
Come over here.
They're doing graffiti!
Come here, come here.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Wait!
I wanna get through the hoop!
Oh my gosh, wait.
We actually have it.
Okay, hold on.
This is a good line-up.
It's a
good line-up.
Oh my god!
Why didn't it work?!
Jammer Sammy!
How
do we get that one?
I like the music in this area too.
Can I push this?
No.
Only destroyed.
Wait!
Can I push this?
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh!
Only destroy.
What's here?
Oh, let's grab cans.
Can I reach that?
Wait, can I reach that?
Oh, jump dash?
With the dash?
With the dog?
Nice!
Good job, everybody.
Good job, team.
How am I supposed to get those up there?
How?
Oh my gosh, there's so much up there!
There's a guy!
Uh-oh.
Okay, hold on.
Did I mess up?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
I see you, I see you, I see you!
I'm coming!
Oh, that was close.
That was close, that was close.
Oh gosh, this one's going to be tricky.
Weep!
I might...
be a gamer.
I might be a gamer.
I might be the gamer who ever lived.
Actually...
I'm not even alive.
I might be...
the gamer who ever died.
Why?
Oh,
was I supposed to make it through the hole, or...
I know.
Should I do it again?
It's down.
Should I try again?
Or...
No.
It's down.
It's going to lift back up.
Well, at least we destroyed him.
The absolute gamer that ever games.
It shows you can leap back!
That's what I said?
Here's our chance!
Redo!
3-0 right now.
I don't think I made it again.
There we go!
I made it through the hole!
But nothing happened.
Oh my god.
Like a ball pit.
Yeah, pretty much.
Got him, baby!
Got him!
What about the guy that stole our friend?
Is he still alive?
Is there anything in here?
Guys, there's probably a secret in here.
Sorry, dog.
This side definitely is a secret.
Never mind.
There's gotta be something in here.
There's gotta be a secret in here.
Just a box.
This time, Minto, it's just a box.
Why does this platform exist if there's nothing here?
I got... something.
Do you guys know that one indie animation thing that went viral?
It was so well animated, but it was a bunch of beans.
That's exactly what this guy looks like.
Like the killer bean!
Yeah, it's a bunch of beans.
That's exactly what this guy looks like.
Looks like the killer bean.
Oh my gosh, I'm destroying the platform?
That's crazy.
Where are you going?
Okay, alright.
We got this guy.
We got this...
We've got...
We've got this.
Who do you think is gonna be our little...
Yeah!
Who do you think is gonna be...
Our thing... our...
Who the hell is that?
What's this?
There's so much everywhere.
A photo spot!
Ew, they keep pooping!
Ew, gross!
Ew, they're eating their own poo!
This is so nasty!
Oh my god, save us!
Why are there so many birds?
Oh, please.
Get me out of this hell!
I think that was it.
Wait.
But I can go...
I should go down.
We should go down.
This way.
This way!
Okay.
Poopies don't feel very stable.
Oh my gosh!
Where's this guy?
Come
on!
Come...
Oh!
Come on!
Oh, I have to find the platforms!
Oh my gosh!
Oh!
Wow!
Am I shooting the right way?
Okay.
I think we're good.
Oh god.
Love-struck lyricist!
A cool pooch with the power of self-belief!
Palapa!
He's so cute!
Awesome.
Wait.
So...
Okay, cool.
Okay.
Let's go this way!
Alright.
Onwards.
I have not played Palapa.
I have not!
How
am I supposed to take care of this guy?
You should.
Oh!
That was close!
Hi!
And I have to...
Which way do I go?
Something
on my back?
Or they have something on their backs?
They look like the...
Um...
They look like...
Uh...
Death Stranding.
Hover over him with your lasers!
Oh, my lasers.
That's right!
That was a way to kill.
Okay.
Yeah!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh!
It's gone.
I hope there was nothing else there.
Hahaha!
Oh!
Sit up!
Thank you!
Ready?
Yeah!
Alright, we just have the one last one.
Just the one last one.
Nice.
Get out
of here.
Oh my gosh, you can even punch the water.
Who is that over there?
Oh my gosh!
Wait, who is that?
Shredding Sheep.
Oh, why rap when you can shred?
So cute!
Oh, she's also from Parappa.
Wait a second.
Did I see something below?
Or am I crazy?
What's that down there?
I do!
I see something below!
How can we make it?
Oh, not through here.
And there's even a jumpy platform here.
Okay, okay.
We can just fall here, I think.
Hahaha!
Aha!
What is this?
I'm feeling.
I'm feeling with my heart.
This one.
Yippee!
Aha!
We got all of them!
I think we're so good at this game.
Oh, I have to dash through here.
Nice!
Why did the music stop?
What happened to the fun music?
Oh my god!
I'm gonna get caught!
Oops.
Hahaha!
Okay.
I got caught.
No worries!
Oh.
No!
Ow!
I keep...
I keep forgetting how to press buttons.
Gamer!
I'm gaming!
Oh.
Uh.
But.
Ah!
Gamed
so much there.
So cute.
Go!
Astra!
Uh.
We did enough.
It's fine.
Oh.
Uh.
You gonna come back?
Nice.
Oh.
I have cheese here.
I've completely forgot.
Oh my gosh.
I was eating my cheese and crackers.
Oh.
I wanna sacrifice my guys for this?
There's just one guy in here.
Ape escape, you think?
You think so?
You think this is gonna be ape escape?
That'd be awesome.
Wait.
Oh.
What's in here?
Yah!
What do we get?
Oh!
We get dog bath.
I should've known from the ape...
from the monkey right here.
I hear like some...
I hear something.
I hear like a guy like...
in my ear.
Do you hear that?
It sounds like a monkey like in my ear.
Hmm.
Is that my dog?
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
It sounded like it was coming from below but maybe it is my dog.
I just didn't hear it before with the dog.
Oh.
Maybe because the music was louder.
Oh wait.
No.
I'm not ready.
There's gotta be a secret here.
Nothing?
Oh!
Oh no!
The crazy...
Sorry.
I just thought there was a secret.
That's all.
Oh.
Shoot.
Ah!
I...
I've missed the...
Oh my goodness.
It takes us...
It takes us back kinda far though.
Oh.
Ah!
See guys?
Obligatory lurker membu chat.
Thanks Siege.
Nathan welcome to membu ship.
Thank you.
That's not what I would do to you.
By the way.
You know.
Um.
So don't worry.
Oh.
Unless you want.
Unless you're just like damn.
I wish she'd beat me to a pulp.
Oh.
I wish she'd beat me until I turn into little scrap pieces.
Whoa.
That was close.
Why are you guys blushing?
Whoa.
Ah!
Oh.
Whoops.
Um.
Ah!
Oh.
We're about to go banana.
What does that say?
Go...
Ghost.
Suck a banana?
Like there's a...
What's this?
It says...
Go sui.
Go...
Sssssss...
Oh wait.
It's a C.
Ko...
Sui...
S...
Sauce?
Go sui sssss...
Hey I'm not there yet.
Chill out.
I guess I'm just saying I don't want to die.
I guess there's not very many secrets here, huh?
Oh, Cosmic!
Where's the M?
Is the U an M?
No.
I don't see it.
And in fact, I refuse to.
Here we go!
Gorilla!
Ah!
Mighty Chewie!
Sweet!
We're almost there!
Oh, we got some stuff.
I don't know what that is though.
Ew!
What are you...
Gross!
Why are you eating your monkeys?
Go!
Sweet!
Are you gonna... Are you done?
Take
his eye!
Oh my god!
Holy cow!
He's gonna become Big Boss Monkey!
That's why they trained us for the hole!
Oh!
Nasty!
Oh gosh!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Yeah!
You can't see anything!
You're stressing me out!
Why are you chomping?
Oh my god!
Beat up his teeth!
He has no teeth now!
Where are you gonna hide your monkeys?
How are you chewing?
Here, think of...
Oh my God!
Think of your dentist!
Please!
Oh, here we go, here we go.
Huh!
Ew!
Easy!
Bleah, bleh, bleh.
Bleah, bleh, bleh, bleh.
Who's in there?   m!
A va
my  HORROR!
Here we go!
Here we
go!
Yeah!
Bye, monkey!
Monkey University!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, what is this?
Is this a new world?
Ape-san!
Holy cow!
Oh wait, I think that's the Statue of Liberty.
I thought it was a graduation gown.
Wait, let's go back home real quick.
Excuse me.
Wait!
Wait, let's catch this guy.
Dang it!
Where did he go?
Crumble...
Rumble...
Interesting.
She said the word.
What word?
Oh, I missed the puzzle piece.
We got another one.
What
is this?
Oh!
Holy cow.
Retro Rampage!
And then...
Rolling Star.
Rolling Star?
Wait, you think Katamari is here?
Must be.
We'll go to that one next.
After I go back to home planet.
Hello, everybody.
I have returned.
Snake!
Did you miss me?
What is this?
Good or nice?
Oh!
License to spend.
The gum.
The gacha.
Wow, they spell gacha with a T like I used to.
Only old-timers spell it with a T.
Time to spend all those coins you've collected.
What are we building now?
Let's go gambling!
Wait, what is it building now?
This one?
Is this the closet?
Oh, dual speeder garage.
When do I get the closet?
I want to become Snake!
Snake!
Hi there!
It fills me with such joy.
Oh, gacha, gacha!
Wait, I have a question.
I have a question.
Are the coins used for anything else?
Are the coins used for anything else or just gacha?
Because I...
It
was my birthday yesterday.
Any chance I can get a happy birthday?
Of course!
So that's what I want to say.
But I really want to thank you for just being you.
I hope you can get a happy birthday from me next year too.
Of course you can!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Margot Rose.
Happy birthday!
This one's for you!
Gacha?
How do I?
A pool!
What did I get?
A crate whacker!
Oh!
As good as any wrench.
Cute.
What does that mean?
Oh!
I got a soda!
Crash it!
Oh!
What?
Sunny's sixth string!
This guitar is not in your mind.
How much does it cost?
Cunning disguise.
Will fool any enemy guard.
Look at him!
He's even...
Solid state.
Let me see...
Let me peek in there.
Let's keep going!
Crash?
Birds!
Squawky.
Oh!
It's the...
That guy from...
Yeah!
Crash!
Protective spirit.
Makes you feel invincible.
I'll be honest.
I never played actual Crash Bandicoot.
But I played...
Um...
So...
The...
I had...
I own the racing one.
You know?
Oh!
A cleaver!
A cleaver piece of weaponry.
Hunting essentials.
Yeah!
Crash team racing!
Cute!
Pop-up pal.
Oh!
Alucard's...
What is going on there?
Oh!
It's his alarm clock.
Somewhere to rest in peace.
Bing bing bing bing bing bing bing bing!
Kan kan kan kan kan kan kan!
I'm awake!
Oh!
Cute!
Oh my god!
Stop!
So cute!
I love...
Um...
Parappa's design.
So cute!
Next!
Oh!
Wisecracking sidekick!
Ah!
We got Daxter!
Has a side hustle as a...
That is Daxter, right?
Has a side hustle as a bug exterminator.
Yep!
Oh my gosh!
Hurt me more, snake!
Next!
Did we get anything for Psycho Mantis?
Ah!
The nostalgia box!
Did that controller just move?
Also, look how funny this is.
The controller...
Okay...
I...
Oh!
The controller is vibrate...
The controller is vibrating!
Vibration is back, baby!
Um...
Uh...
I posted this on Twitter, actually.
But...
I...
A lot of people were like...
Oh!
The controller should be plugged into...
Port 2!
Into the second port!
Because, you know...
That's what you do when you fight...
Psycho Mantis.
But...
Um...
If you look closely...
It's plugged into the memory card slot.
It's not even plugged into the controller port!
Yeah...
Also, he's vibrating it.
So it must be the first port.
Exactly!
But also...
It's plugged into the memory card slot!
Hahaha!
Oh my gosh!
So cute!
Stop!
I'm not a nerd!
Anybody would notice!
The vibration slot!
Wowee!
Alright, last one!
Oh!
Ready to get cracking!
Hahaha!
You look so evil!
Heheh!
Bop!
Why was there only... Oh, out of stock!
Find more special boss or puzzle pieces and new gacha...
Oh, so...
I guess I was destined to get those because they're the only characters I have.
Spank!
Thanks for the 30 gifted!
Give him his bed.
More stuff to get.
Come give me items!
Oh!
I know I just summoned you and I'm literally stealing from you.
Come here!
Come here, birds!
Visit Snake?
I will!
Hold on!
Nice!
Oh, that was close.
I feel like we almost didn't get that.
Let's go see Snake in his box.
Oh!
Yeah, okay, okay, okay.
Wait, did we get anything for Ratchet?
Gosh!
The stealth camo!
If you hit them, they react?
Snake, you dog!
You!
Snake!
Isn't a buddy girl!
Snake, you dog!
You!
Oh!
So cute!
Oh my gosh!
Okay, next outfit, buddy girl outfit.
How embarrassing.
That's like the equivalent of peeing yourself, you know?
Oh my god!
Get a hold of yourself, man!
That is a robot in there.
So cute!
Oh, we meant to do that!
Oh yeah!
It was all part of the plan!
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Ooh-ah!
Ba-da-ba-da-ba!
Ba!
So smooth.
Uh,
this one.
His hair.
This is so silly.
Oh!
Oh
my gosh!
I didn't even notice that there were skelly-bots!
They're so cute!
Cute!
They're so, so cute.
Oh, that's it?
Okay.
Fun!
Alrighty.
Shall we continue?
The hunter hits back.
He parried you.
He's too good.
Alright!
Alright, alright.
Is that all for now?
Oh, it has been three hours.
You know what?
Maybe...
I will call it here, maybe.
Maybe I will call it here.
Woo!
Hit snake again, please.
Okay!
Yeah, good endpoint.
I think so.
I hope you guys liked this.
If you guys liked it...
Oh, you saluted me!
Okay, I'm going to beat him there.
You'll never make it, snake.
Come on!
Can you make it?
Go!
Oh,
he's just like a little baby.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Wait, does it do something different every time?
Or like after the third time?
Ah!
Oh, no?
Snake is just special?
Some have several animations.
Snake is special!
Asuka, asuka!
Yeah, I think I'm going to call it here for today.
I hope you guys liked this.
I had so much more fun.
And... like, I know people were saying this is a really good game, but I honestly had way more fun than I expected to.
And I think, you know, obviously it's like... so much fun to see these characters, you know, and everything, so...
But the game itself is also just a lot of fun to play.
So... overall... probably we'll come back to this if you guys liked it, though.
So... yeah!
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
Because I gotta get a changing room!
Gotta get the changing room!
Didn't even feel like you were with the jet hag.
I'm not feeling it so much right now.
Hopefully I can actually fall asleep.
I'm kind of worried that, like, this gave me a new...
A bit of energy, and I won't be able to sleep until...
But I have to wake up early-ish tomorrow.
So... yeah.
Joy, princess, thank you!
Firebug, thanks for the tiny gift, and thank you so much!
Yeah!
Um...
Tomorrow is Holocure!
So... I'll be playing that.
And... excited, excited, excited.
Excited for all the games this week.
And karaoke on Friday.
And... um...
Metal Gear Solid 3!
You guys...
I know I have...
The jet lag right now.
Oh my gosh!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Um...
Uh... I know I...
Have the jet lag now.
Guys, I'm going back to Japan at the end of this...
Actually, I have to change my flight a little bit.
Because...
I was only gonna go for, like, three days.
For some idle stuff.
That's really, really, really important to me.
But now...
Oh my gosh!
Stop!
Thank you for another birthday!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Please!
I know it's your birthday!
But please!
Spoil yourself!
It's done!
But, um...
I'm changing my date so I can also go to TGS.
So, um...
But I will only be gone for, like, a couple days.
Not, like, a long, long time.
Just a couple days.
That's because of the Delta booth, isn't it?
Yes!
I have to play the demo!
Japan fun...
No, no.
Please don't support this.
But honestly...
I wasn't...
I wasn't going to go.
But, um...
You're straight up crazy, man.
Crazy.
I wasn't gonna go.
Even though...
Um...
One of my idol Oshis was graduating.
I was just like, you know what?
I guess I'll just never see her again.
I didn't even get to see her once this past trip.
So, um...
Uh, you know...
I was like, I guess I'll just never see her again.
And then, um...
Basically...
Um...
A group that I really love...
They disbanded in...
In 2020.
And...
Because it was, you know...
During COVID, they didn't get to have, like, a actual, like, final show.
It was only online.
But...
Um...
And at this group, I think about them basically every single day.
I love them so much.
And after they disbanded, honestly, I...
I...
It was really hard for me to get back into idols because I was, like, so...
I was so distraught over losing them.
And...
And just for one day...
For one day, they're coming back.
And I get to see my Oshi.
For one day...
She...
Is not an idol anymore.
So...
It's like...
A mega rare chance.
And she's not gonna become an idol again, probably.
So...
I was like...
I just...
I just wanna say bye to her.
And then, also, it was TGS at the same time.
So, basically, it's gonna be a very emotional...
A very emotional weekend for me.
Meeting Oshi Group 5.
Thank you.
So, I'm really sorry.
Oh my gosh, Paul!
Shut the fuck up!
Shut up!
I'm ending the stream!
The stars align.
It really feels like that.
I get to see my Oshi for the last time.
I get to see two of my Oshis for the last time ever.
And I get to play Delta.
Maybe.
Hopefully.
Fingers crossed.
Because TGS is kind of insane.
But...
The stars have aligned!
So, I feel like I have to do it.
I'm really sorry.
That I'm going back to Japan.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry!
But...
And it's gonna be actually pretty close to my birthday.
Which...
If you guys don't know...
My birthday...
Is...
October!
It's October 1st!
October 1st is my birthday!
So...
You better come to my birthday.
And...
Um...
I actually have two things planned for my birthday.
One for October 1st.
Hopefully.
If I can get it done in time.
And then another stream...
Um...
With...
Some...
Announcements?
Perhaps?
What could it be?
So...
Yeah!
Hahaha!
Um...
I...
I have been cooking a lot.
Especially since I got back from Japan.
Like...
I know I've only been back for like...
A day.
But I was like...
E-mailing.
I was...
Messaging.
I was doing...
I was like...
Pumping out stuff.
So...
Yeah!
Oh, shoot.
Sorry.
I'm going to Japan on that day.
Stop!
Hahaha!
Um...
Oh, yeah.
So...
Um...
I'm going to take another Japan trip in October.
No!
Hahaha!
I hope not.
I'm so tired of...
I...
Like...
I think I said...
Me and Matara kind of mentioned this on the podcast before.
How like...
You know...
I...
I wouldn't be able to...
Even go and see my Oshis if it wasn't for you guys.
So...
Like...
To complain just feels...
I...
I can't even complain.
You know?
But I am a bit traveled out.
Hahaha!
I'm a bit travel...
Done.
I'm done with traveling.
Hahaha!
I even had to decline some...
Some like conventions and...
And events and stuff that wanted me to travel there.
And I was like...
I'm sorry.
I...
I can't...
I can't do it.
It's no good.
But also...
I just...
I...
Also...
One of the things...
I'm gonna stream.
I've missed streaming so much.
I've missed streaming consistently so much.
So it's really...
This is me.
This...
This little robot guy is me.
Hahaha!
I'm dead.
I'm dead on the ground.
Just dead on the ground.
Can't do it.
Will you still be in Japan on October 1st?
I've heard a few screens in Akiba Station might be haunted then.
What do you mean by that?
I don't know.
What
do you mean by that?
What do you mean by that?
What do you...
Thanks guys for the stream.
I had a lot of fun.
I hope you guys did too.
I will see you guys tomorrow or whenever I see you.
When I see you, I'll see you.
And...
I'll see you guys later!
Bye!
Bye bye!
Thank you!
What if this was the outro instead?